this is a one-dimensional single
dimensional inequality okay I've only
got a single dimension I can move along
forwards or backwards okay and that's
because I've only got a single variable
okay yeah very much so
when we add in another variable when we
add it in without variable what happens
okay so for instance X is less than Y X
is less than Y this should be revision I
hurt which is why few years sheet
straight away because we've got an extra
variable we're gonna have an extra
dimension as well okay so a number line
which is just goes back to the fourth
one - I'm gonna need a number plane okay
no blind number plane
okay now all the inequalities right they
haven't called boundary a spot where it
starts and stops okay a spot where it
starts is that just like these okay
now have a look at these ones for a
second cuz it's simply okay what is the
boundary of the inequality X is greater
than 3 the boundary is X is equal to 3
right so we took the whole thing and we
just put an equal sign there that gives
us a single position the banner at the
border of your life and it's the same
deal for X is less than 2 I just say
take the inequality sign way making
equals and that's your maverick okay
saved you for these two-dimensional
inequalities so what's the boundary that
defines this it's gonna be X is equal to
1 okay so what you do is you take that
line and you draw it in just like we
took that spot and we've we marked it
okay yeah let's see quickly
x equals y looks like this alright
we're very very comfortable we're
thinking about left and right unless
they're in greater than but which side
of this boundary for upper side or the
lower side which side are we on
okay oh you should label your battery
too by the way
the easiest way to tell is just a peak
point and test it okay we come back to
you like say one zero one zero okay so
that's shorthand for x equals 1 y equals
zero all right that's what it means so
I'm gonna take these two values and
stick them in see what happens okay so X
equal to 1 1 is less than Y which is 0
is it a true statement it's not a true
statement right so that means the point
I picked get this this is why I write
down the value I pick the point up it
doesn't see the satisfy the inequality
so that's not the region I'm going to
shape okay it's the other one so get
another color
and that's it I'm done
okay so if